bianca holman revving things up for us
this morning oh my goodness bianca
what time does the grand prix start i
love it
[Music]
hey
john hey heather so you see we're ready
to take off almost we're here at optima
batteries they've been doing donuts and
spin outs that we've been hearing since
yesterday and i'm here with chris who's
been driving he's only 21 but he's been
driving for a decade i trust him how you
doing chris good it's bright and early
we're ready to go having fun today we're
going to be putting on a lot of shows
and a lot of burnouts a lot of high
horsepower stuff yeah so how was
yesterday how many people did you take
out oh yesterday i got to take over 10
lucky vips it's been so much fun out
here at the optima booth we've been
scaring people having a little fun and
now it's your chance all right it's my
turn so
we're gonna
y'all watch
john heather you gotta you gotta show
the people you're gonna be navigating
this for us so i gotta put my mic down
i'm holding on oh my goodness here we go
she's buckled up folks i feel like
that's we talked before heather about
how they're having electric cars they're
highlighting i get to know that it's not
electric
oh my goodness there it goes eh oh wow
oh bianca
i wonder if they have a barf bag in them
no no
no just a little donut nothing
look at that okay she's brave but you
know when we hear
if you're near the convention you can
hear the donuts this is what they're
doing my goodness
he knows what he's doing he said what
did he say high horsepower high
horsepower high horsepower just freaking
out some of the uh spectators at sema
and bianca bianca bianca will never see
your bianca again i know hopefully we've
got the helmet on can we hear the engine
going
oh there we go here we go
he's still going
i feel like he's waking himself up too
for me
that felt good that felt good y'all okay
i could feel the power
hey you're not first you're laughing no
sign me up chris oh yeah you're ready
next round you're driving
great it's me next i'm gonna get in the
driver's seat oh i love that great time
thanks so much for seema for showing us
some great hospitality out here great
products and again this feels good
can we do one more chris let's do it
ready
all right see you later braver than i am
wow go bianca